so everything's normal now headliner
uncontrollably cool not the headliner so
you don't even have to try it for me but
uh you guys should listen to me because
I have a lot of confidence right now
thank you my wire respect me so much is
my confidence and I think calm is very
important because without confidence
stupid people would have no idea I'm
gonna pay attention to they just be
running around out here oh where am I
what am i doing what am i hearing
oh hey that guy's making strong noises
it's all this guy called elections it's
not easy I hear from one so sapiosexual
as myself I'm looking for a girlfriend
who is not only beautiful but also
intellectually stimulated by the mental
exercise of finding me attracting like
no is it a puzzle
holy [ __ ] you are you that tonight okay
I can make it as now
hi I'm dating because I'm not that into
anime but anyone who is sexually
attracted to me they're pretty into
anime wresting anime face I can't help
it I'm on a day though I am a shoe or
the nose country Chinese province in
china called south korea province I like
to eat General Tso's chicken he's my
general apollomon it means good chicken
but my Asian friends gotta get all up in
my business that icon isn't General
Tso's chicken just a shitty Americanized
version of something technically Asian
and I'm like yeah
okay my movies my geometry is really
into yoga and joke sex I was like dude
do you enjoy breathing or not God a
Millennials so you know it's hard I hear
I went to New York recently and they had
extra security in New York City on 9/11
as the day that's a problem is the day
those liberal 11 days into September
these sermons they get a little cuvee
that's right crazy let's just keep an
eye on this day I love rednecks know
don't get me wrong
rednecks are great because they could
survive in any wilderness situation that
you put them in except a situation where
everyone has equal rights
you can let us walk with an alligator
why can't live in that cold sack with a
minority figured out I find that funny
when Americans will say communism never
works as if we didn't spend billions of
dollars and kill millions of people to
make sure it wouldn't work
remember Vietnam because they're pretty
anxious about an hour again communism
never works because whatever people
control the means of production they're
democratically elected leaders
mysteriously died small rebel group
always finds automatic weapons to pay
them I am NOT a communist okay I just
support any policies that Republicans
would consider communism which is
whenever two or more people gather to do
something nice can't take a joke oh you
guys are the Republican Party you know
you guys are supposed to be more
animalistic but you can't you can't
laugh at this good laughing it's very
primal and they're capable of it no I'm
fine I'm fine of it I'm fine with
Republicans okay so my best friends are
alone again get off my back I like the
name black people now
I got myself a line okay I feel you can
take one you know politics it's great
I'll tell people will say make America
great again because children a hero
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]